trump's an anomaly he's his own weird
thing
he certainly is a troublemaker by
temperament to a fair degree
and a trickster and he was very good at
that i mean look
he was a democrat so i don't really know
what to make of him
what was your reaction when you heard
about the fact that the 45th president
united states was being
banned permanently in a very powerful
virtual government called twitter
i thought that companies who are doing
such things have no idea what to police
the content of what's being exchanged on
their
networks why do you think opposition
doesn't want you to know what he's
thinking
a large part of the american population
felt silenced
they're scared he has the power of a
demagogue that he could harness the
crowd for nefarious ends they view him
as a mussolini in the making
how much of this has to do with your
book beyond order rule number six
abandon ideology i think that's
something that we are struggling with as
a nation
well people struggle with it all the
time because we're attracted to
oversimplifications and it's no wonder
because the complexity of the world is
daunting and some of it's just a matter
of not being taught to think
well which is kind of where we are today
though the less we think the more we can
be controlled
my guest today is clinical psychologist
dr jordan peterson who's been on
valuetainment two times before
and he is back for the third we are very
happy to have him
his book in 2018 was ranked number one
in non-fiction in us
canada uk australia new zealand sweden
the netherlands
brazil norway slater for translation in
50 plus languages that book 12
rules for life that change millions of
people's
lives and uh finally we decided let's
figure something out to bring him back
on everybody's excited about his new
book that just came out
beyond order 12 more rules for life with
that being said dr jordan peterson thank
you so much for being a guest again
on valuetainment good to see you i'm i'm
looking forward to speaking with you
so so how are things how you doing
increasingly better increasingly better
that's great to hear
yeah yeah i'm i'm working quite
effectively for three hours a day now
up from zero and so three hours is a lot
more than zero and i'm working every day
for about three hours and i'm starting
to expand
that so i'm getting i've been diagnosed
with sleep apnea very severe
sleep apnea and so i now have a machine
to deal with that and that seems to have
helped a lot i
i wasn't really sleeping at all
apparently so
that's relevant and it's been very
helpful to have that addressed and i've
adapted to the machine quite rapidly
now it has has your wife adapted to the
machine because it's pretty noisy if
it's the one i think it is the new ones
are very quiet
okay good that's very very quiet
non-obtrusive and and
it's much better than not sleeping i got
to tell you i've been watching you on
camera the last few months just to see
because you can tell a lot from
someone's eyes that the fire looks like
it's coming back in those eyes your eyes
today seem very
different than uh the last uh few months
it's it sounds like your your energy's
coming back up it seems like uh
the equilibrium is coming back up if
that makes any sense but just watching
you the way you look right now you look
great
thank you i appreciate that so so you
know
uh obviously you know we missed you
2020 and 2019 uh
with the whole catastrophic time that we
went through with covet i mean it was a
very strange
time that we went through and there was
a lot of times where you know you would
turn
to see what this person's saying let me
see what he's saying about today's times
what is she saying what are they saying
it's like let me see what jordan's
saying oh
he's not here with us while you were
going through your
uh phase of you know
recovery working on yourself getting
yourself back to
where you used to be how were you
sitting there were you following the
news were you following what's going on
were you sitting there saying oh my gosh
this is crazy
i gotta say something about this
somebody give me a mic i want to say
something about this
but you couldn't did you feel like you
were
silenced where you couldn't see it say
anything or were you just not in a
position where you didn't follow
the news you didn't follow anything that
was going on well in 2019
i was preoccupied with my wife's illness
and and that just took me out of the
public realm
pretty much all together except when it
was absolutely unavoidable
because it was day-to-day catastrophe
for
months on end and before that it was my
daughter for for a month because she had
a serious surgery and so that i was out
of
public uh i was out of public eye
and not concerned with public issues for
about nine months then and then i got
very ill and so
i was watching what was going on with
covet and of course it was affecting my
family and i we were in florida for mo
for much of that my parents were with me
and my sister and some other family
members and now and then some friends
and
so we were all affected by that just as
everyone was but
i never really felt that i had anything
particularly intelligent to say about
covid i mean it's it's a catastrophe
um economically and and from the
perspective of health but
it i didn't feel that i had any insights
that were going to be
extraordinarily useful to people i think
it was just as well that i
kept my mouth shut during that period
and besides that i was in no shape to
craft a careful argument and put it in
front of the public
so well so
if i had to miss a year i suppose this
was a pretty good year to miss
that makes sense if you had a messy year
it was a good year to miss
yeah my son had it my son and his wife
had a baby
and so that was a blessing in the midst
of all this catastrophe and
so when i did want to focus on something
that was outside that was
available right there once i got back
home so
you know that was that was the positive
part of the year for us
or at positive part of the year you said
when your wife got diagnosed with
cancers that if i'm getting debates
right i don't know maybe off april of
2019 is that the right time
well she was actually diagnosed in 2018
but we were told to begin with that it
was
a common and easily treatable very slow
growing tumor and then it turned out to
be
uh not that at all it turned out to be
something that was
virtually was fatal in virtually all
cases and very rare
and so it was and and then she had a
tremendous amount of surgical trauma
that lasted for months
that that was also life-threatening on a
day-to-day basis
i want to show you something i'm going
to show you a video of yourself
we you and i were together in las vegas
at the same event where i had the late
kobe bryant at with the president bush
and jordan peterson and uh billy bean if
you remember that event
we're at mirage there's about 7 000
people there i'm asking you a question
about
your kids and this was your answer
and your reaction and i want to come
back and ask you this is to give you the
dates
so we can date this this is july 31st of
2019. so
watch the video and then i want to get
your reaction from it sure
little children pay you back
immensely if you have
a good relationship with them you know
if you're on their side
and encourage them because they're
an unconditional source of
joy and love
powerful
you know the
the other thing i noticed that you
should that
that you should all know is that
as you get older
your family the family you've produced
becomes more and more important
you know so we teach young women in
particular
that the fundamental goal of their life
is going to be their career
and you know first of all most people
don't have careers they have jobs
and those are very different things but
you're not a very happy camper so to
speak if you're
45 and you have no one
and it doesn't go upwards after that
that was july 31st 2019
when i interviewed you and i walked away
you know you and i had sat down together
once before in dallas when he came to
the office and we
had a great conversation together i
walked away after the interview i said
you know this guy's dealing with
something there's something very heavy
that he's dealing with right now and you
know even
upcoming to the event you said you know
your wife was going through challenging
times and you still made the event up
until the day we didn't know if you were
going to make it or not but you were
able to make it and i was very impressed
the fact that you made it
but give you one of the very few events
i did that year
and we were very grateful for it and you
positively impacted a lot of people's
lives
many people made some major decisions in
their lives after that even based on the
words
that you shared with them but can you
can you kind of
you know let us know where were you at
what were you thinking about on july 31
2019 well i mean i was
i was thinking that there was a high
probability that i was going to lose my
wife
so um that seemed virtually certain
and so that was and i watched the
consequences of that for my kids
and and her family and you know it
brought home to me
and i had been traveling around a lot as
well
and seeing people who were lonesome and
hurt
because their family structure was not
what they needed it to be
and so i was also seeing a lot of that
and carrying that around in some sense
because
i've seen a lot of misery in in people
as a consequence of all the public
lecturing i've been doing and also just
walking around because people come up to
me all the time and
tell me about their life in a very uh
open way very rapidly and
and so all of that was affecting me um
and i had my own health troubles at the
time as well so
but i think another part of what was
affected me was that
while that was happening i had a
tremendous outpouring of support
there was a tremendous outpouring of
support from me and my family
from our extended family
who we almost always had someone from
our extended family tammy's sister
or my sister my mother or tammy's
brother
with us they stayed with us for weeks on
end
and my friends as well and my friends
have been
unbelievably helpful to me they've gone
way out of their way to
help me during this time some of them
went to russia when i was there
and uh came down to florida to stay for
long periods of time and then also the
same thing happened
on the public level we had hundreds of
letters
well tammy was in the hospital my sister
printed those out in color and
put them up in the hospital room and
that was really helpful and
i think it affected my last book too
because the book has a more
communitarian
ethos than the first one i'm i've become
much
more sensitive to the the cooperative
role that people play in
making each other better and because i
do believe that each individual in some
sense
is obligated to to work towards their
own salvation so to speak and
you can think about that agnostically if
you want you you need to do good in the
world
and it's the most rewarding possible
thing to do and your conscience tortures
you if you don't do that and
that's very unpleasant and so everyone
in
in the deepest part of them they're
highly motivated to to make things
better
and that's that is something you do
individually but it's also something
that you do with a tremendous amount of
help
and you can also be helpful to others
and i've seen so much of that so
so many people were so helpful to us
that it just
shocked me and that includes the public
who
the members because i didn't know for
example when i came back
in november because that's sort of when
i started re-entering
public life to some degree i had no idea
how i would be treated
you know and i was ambivalent about the
morality of my illness because
you know what's been broadly reported
was that
i developed a dependence on
benzodiazepines which is true but
i was also extremely ill before i took
them
which is why i took them to begin with
and i still don't know why
that was exactly i haven't figured that
out or or know if it's going to go away
but it's certainly been the case that
people have been unbelievably helpful
and
and so all that was in my mind when i
was talking on stage
it's always in my mind i suppose yeah
and obviously the tour you did
you know we're talking about 160 cities
i don't know how many countries you went
to 500 000 tickets sold you went all
over the world
like you were on tour regularly
traveling going all over the place
what was tougher for you was it tougher
for you to come out
and tell the world what you were
struggling with or was it tough to
come back from that because your image
when we think about
the image of jordan peterson it's it's
values it's prince of
principles it's what many men
uh uh see an example like you know i
want to be like this man one day that i
want to be able to follow a strong
example of somebody like him
uh uh was it tougher for you to come out
and tell the world i'm
dealing with this addiction or was it
more when i come back how is the world
going to receive me are they going to
welcome you which one was tougher for
you
oh i i think they were both almost
insufferably
tough you know i mean and i wasn't
really in a position to defend myself in
some sense because i didn't know exactly
what had happened
to me i still really don't know um
you know but i'd already decided at that
point
long before that point that the way to
deal with
complex issues is just to say what you
think about them
you know i wasn't trying to craft a
message that would ease my
re-entrance into the public life again
i was trying to pick up the pieces of my
life and move forward
but i wasn't i thought
how to handle everything that happened i
just said what had happened is
to the best of my ability and that is
what i try to do
i'm not trying to craft a message for a
particular purpose
i'm other than maybe i'm trying i'm
hoping that i'm trying to make things
better
that's a purpose but it's kind of
abstract in some sense
but what i'm doing apart from that is
just trying to say what i believe
to be the case at the moment and i've
really been thinking about that a lot
lately too because
like i have a formal technique for my
lectures hey
so when i sit down to give a lecture i i
sit down for 20 minutes beforehand
i have to be alone and i have to go into
kind of a reverie
and and so i relax and then i think okay
well what problem am i going to talk
about tonight
and i don't mean that i'm going to
supply an answer i'm
what i'm going to do is to try to push
my thinking about
the answer to that problem and the
problem itself how it should be
formulated
farther than i've managed to push it so
far
and then i think well here's the ideas
that i can draw on
to walk through that prop that process
of
problem specification and analysis and
then we'll just see what happens we'll
see how that goes and
and so then it's it's it's spontaneous
thought that's happening on stage
um you know i use pieces of things that
i've already thought up
but that doesn't matter they're combined
in an original way to the degree that i
can do that in real time
and i think the reason that that
engrosses the audience is
partly because it's it is a genuine
approach
attempt to further an exploration of
truth at least insofar as i can
formulate it and so
and then it's also in some sense like a
story because
i can lay out an argument from start to
end and
everyone can follow along with it and
then i've been trying to figure out what
i'm doing in podcasts or what podcasts
are good for
and i think it's exactly the same thing
in that they're a real revolutionary
replacement for standard
mainstream media journalistic interviews
for example
you know when a podcast really works you
and you tell me what you think about
this i mean
my experience is that when a podcast
really works you have two people who
are uh exploring a set of concepts
mutually and they're they're engaged in
a genuine process of
the exchange of ideas so it's
dialectical thinking it's real-time
dialectical thinking and i think of it
as
it's it's a manifestation of the logos
all things considered and that's
compelling because
it's so useful and so it's compelling
because something might
might good might come out of it in terms
of clarification of a problem and maybe
the generation of a solution
but it's also useful as an example
conversation
and so well i was hoping when i
came back to public life that i could
continue doing that and
and so far that seems to be working and
i'm starting to write
again and although that's slow because
writing is very
i find everyone i think finds writing
very difficult
uh but it's coming along and the book
has been received very well
so by the public uh the critics
the the mainstream critics are it
doesn't really matter i guess in some
sense
what what they think they think what i
would have predicted they thought and
and they also seem to generally speaking
have a fair bit of contempt for my
hypothetical audience which i find quite
dis
quieting you know i mean the the correct
the caricature of my audience is angry
young white men
which isn't true it's simply not true
my audience does skew somewhat male
but the rest of it's just a caricature
but even if it was
the case i don't see how trying to help
those people those people the basket of
deplorables let's say
i don't see why that's an immoral
endeavor
and i really understand the hostility
that's being generated
in relationship to maybe to the to
dispossessed to the dispossessed young
to dispossessed young men in
relationship
to the the mainstream media for this
kind of contempt
well i'm not contemptuous of my audience
i'm
i'm thrilled that i can be of use
and i'm trying all the time to figure
out how i can be of more use
you know when i stop when someone stops
me on the street that happens all the
time
they're usually shy and tentative about
stopping me and usually very very polite
almost invariably so
it's never a real imposition and i
always ask people
you know they say if they say that they
watch a lecture and it helped i always
asked them why
you know what helped and so i had three
guys this week
tell me they said well i was comparing
myself
to what other people had achieved and
always coming up
short and that was hurting me it was
making me envious let's say and
disheartening me but then i learned to
reward myself
for small improvements over who i was
and i thought well that's really
important you know because you you are
comparing yourself to the right person
then and now you're rewarding yourself
you're encouraging yourself for taking
the steps that you can
that you can take it's really important
to do that right and
you know now i know that that's
important to my listeners and so i'll
try to formulate that concept more
accurately and
communicate it more clearly it's a great
privilege
it's a great privilege to be able to do
this the with the podcasts and the books
and it's so
it's great it's great jordan let me ask
you this are you would you consider
yourself happy today
no when's the last time you were when's
the last time you were happy
i was happy a little bit last week for
for a couple of hours
i'm in too much pain and to be happy
still
i mean it's not like i don't appreciate
what's good about my life
i do appreciate it and i i remember it
consciously all the time and my wife and
i remind each other about it
constantly um and so i see that all very
clearly and
i can see where the sources of happiness
could lie but
i'm still i have a lot of neurological
damage by all appearances and
it produces quite a lot of pain and so
i'm i'm overcoming that i think bit by
bit like i have a very structured day
so i get up and i have a sauna and then
i walk for six miles and then i exercise
for an hour
quite intensely with weights and i dance
a little bit
to music because while i'm trying to
regain control over all my extremities
and
um that's all working quite well and
then i have the podcasts and so forth
and so
i have a well-structured life but it's
still not to the point where i would say
i was happy
i'd like to get there healthy really is
really what i'd want
healthy and fully functioning i'm
running at about 50 now and
it was down to about five for a long
time
what's the 50 is a lot better no no no
and that's great to hear
what's the longest like if you if you
were to
if you were to put uh outcomes of
life like you would say priorities okay
happiness
i'm living a happy life fulfilled life
healthy life how would you rank those
three for someone like you
oh healthy is by far the most important
but then i wouldn't use those
criteria like i think um
i'm very pleased if i can say things
that i believe to be true
i i don't think there's anything more
rewarding than getting your speech right
and and then also seeing what the
consequence of that was and i've been
thinking about that a lot too i've been
talking to religious leaders
partly on my podcast but also thinking
it through because
mainstream religious leaders are having
a harder and harder time attracting
young people to the church and
that's i don't think that's a good thing
um
even though i don't attend church um
but i was thinking that part of it is
that
that they're not selling a great enough
adventure like the
you know the thing about revolutionary
movements like antifa or black lives
matter something like that is they offer
this
unbelievable romance to young people you
know they can get involved in this
in this fiery cause and they can go to
these
romantically spectacular demonstrations
and it's
it's way more exciting than working at
7-eleven
which i i have no contempt for people
who work at 7-eleven you know like more
power too
you've got a job and some and that job
needs to be done but that's not the
point
there you need an adventure in your life
and these revolutionary movements
offer that but i'm thinking too that you
know
i've tried i've written about this have
pursue what's meaningful and not what's
expedient and i would also
say that it's useful to say what
is true rather than to craft your word
so that you get what you want
and the reason part of the reason for
that there's many reasons but part of
the reason for that is that it's
unbelievably adventurous
you have no idea what will happen if you
just say what you think
and my experience has been that the
consequences are absolutely overwhelming
always constantly and you know when i go
into a talk like this
i don't have a pre i don't have an
outcome in mind i don't want to make a
fool of myself i don't want to say
something stupid
um i want to engage in an interesting
conversation but
but i'm not trying i don't have an
agenda other than that
but it's just to say what i feel in the
moment
as clearly as i possibly can it's so
adventurous to do that
and it's far better than pursuing
a more narrow goal that might be wrong
and so there's an adventure there that
and i i think
one of the things i love about the
long-form video format is that it
enables people to engage in
the mutual uh exploration of truth a
revelation of truth the discovery of
truth and
it's so interesting too that people find
that compelling and exciting and watch
it and want it
and it's it's revolutionary i think and
it's a privilege to be part of that
you know you know why i ask you guys a
question i ask you this question for
for one reason like i think about when i
watch you and michaela together
right and i have a daughter i have a
four-year-old daughter i have a
seven-year-old
son and a nine-year-old son right i mean
a kid wants
their mommy and daddy to be happy that's
why they make him laugh that's why they
win that's why they put grace they want
mommy and daddy to be happy right
i think okay what does michaela want of
pops
you know i bet michaela probably wants
dad to be happy
you know in the next phase of life so
you know what two questions here on the
topic of happiness
what makes jordan happy and when was the
last
time you had the longest stretch of
happiness
what caused it those two questions i'm
curious
oh i had a lot of happiness i would say
when i was on tour
okay uh it was unbelievably exciting
i had some health problems during that
period of time too so sure there was a
shadow there but
that made me happy on a continual base
it was unbelievably exciting and
engaging
i mean people are happy when they're
pursuing something that they find
meaningful deeply meaningful
especially when that's going well on in
a day-to-day level
i find most of my happiness i would say
um
well in engaging conversation that's for
sure but also with my family
and you know that's partly why i said
what i did say when
in that clip that you showed earlier you
know what
makes me most happy right now is when my
family gets together so that's
my immediate family my wife my kids and
their and their spouses and
there's no uh uh there's nothing buried
underneath the rugs
and everyone's joking and laughing and
playing
and that's and it's peaceful it's truly
peaceful and that does happen
i go to see my son quite often he lives
just up the street from me
uh fortunately enough and i really like
his wife and
her jillian is her name and jillian and
my my wife tammy have
really tried to make their relationship
to perfect their relationship to get rid
of any
you know of the cliched mother-in-law
daughter-in-law
trouble and some of that was there to
begin with and they both decided
and i suppose we all decided consciously
as a unit that
we're going to get rid of all of that
and just stop it and
try to have a really good relationship
and that really worked and so now i go
over there and it's
they're happy they're smiling it's
they're it's peaceful there
their their little boy is laughing he's
playing with laughing and so we had some
people over
for easter dinner my son and his wife
and
a couple of friends of theirs and they
had a little baby named florence and
she was also the same age and she was
playing with laughing so she would go
and then this little my grandson elliot
would
go and then all the adults would laugh
because these two
infants were actually having a
conversation with each other a
proto-conversation with laughter
that lasted for about 10 minutes and
everyone was laughing about it and
well there isn't anything better than
that when there isn't
all sorts of horror hidden underneath
the carpets
you know in this new book beyond order i
have a chapter called don't hide things
in the
fog and it's about this it's like
wonderful things can happen if you
straighten out everything that's hidden
in a family and and get it out in the
open and
um and then you you have the opportunity
then for some real peace and some real
joy
and certainly that's at the moment where
it's in those interpersonal interactions
that i derive a lot of my happiness and
that's been life-saving
and then of course the this act of
engaged intellectual conversation
this sort of conversation that we're
doing our best to have that's also
and the fact that i can share that with
so many people and the responses are so
positive
it's wonderful it's amazing i can't
believe it
i can't believe it it's so ridiculous
well we enjoy probably just as much as
you do if not more than you do
you know the the audience enjoys it uh
way more than you probably do because
we're learning and we're figuring out
our lives out but
you know i'm going to a place with these
series of questions i'm asking you years
ago my dad told me something very
interesting
i was a 1.8 gpa kid in high school i
aced math
i loved math i loved numbers everything
else i had no tolerance for it had no
patience
didn't have the happiest life you know
we live in it leave it around we go to
germany i live at that refugee camp for
a couple years
i just couldn't wait to get away from
the reality so i want to join the army
to get some kind of an escape i get out
of the army
and i'm thinking about being a
bodybuilder to be the next arnold
and then all of a sudden i start reading
books
and i in my entire lifetime i read two
books one of them was that was then this
is down the other one was a
mice of man and i didn't even finish it
it was in high school i was
never reader i started reading a book
and then the next one and then the next
one
jordan it got to a point that i just
couldn't put books down
and i wouldn't go out friday nights and
i was a big party guy i was in vegas
every other weekend for a year i was
always at the nightclubs tuesday through
sunday monday is the only day
that i would generally take off or
wednesdays i would take off but i was on
going six nights a week
and then my dad's like what's up with
this reading i said that i'm just let me
tell you
this information is ridiculous can you
imagine like what's in this booklet in
this book i learned this in this book
in this article in this one so you would
never read why reading so much
i said i'm obsessed he says let me give
you a tip he says what's that
he says in my life i have two people one
of them is a guy named
albert who is like an uncle to me
sweetheart of a guy the guy you know
just you love this guy uh he he would
come to our house
didn't speak english at the time i would
watch kings of
kings of comedy and bernie mac would be
doing his skit and
he is laughing so hard jordan
almost as if he has to go to the
bathroom i'm like did you just
understand what
he said he says i have no clue what he
said but it's so funny
i said you don't even know you don't
know what he just said is i have no clue
it's just funny
so my dad says look at albert a happy
simpleton
okay look how much he's enjoying his
life okay
happiest guy to be around you go eat
with them you give him good food he's
happy
people dance he's happy telling stories
he's happy
just a happy guy that's enjoying life he
said now let me tell you about my
brother younger brother my dad's brother
physicist five guy couldn't stop reading
books pipe cigar you know one of those
thinkers
he would read read read read read read
and he couldn't stop
like he would read physics books like he
would read chemistry books
on his own like you weren't it wasn't
homework or anything just you go to his
place he had all these weird books and
he was doing mathematic homeworks on his
own
he said the moment you get caught with
the reading with the bug of
reading and learning and you get
addicted to it
you have to know that your mind is going
to process stuff and the debate starts
happening here
and it's forever it never stops he said
you lose a little bit of happiness
when you go too much about wanting to
get certain questions answered in life
because it's never gonna end
it's forever he says so if you choose to
subscribe to wanting to become a
lifelong learner
be also ready to lose a part of that
happiness and freedom that you once had
when you didn't know everything
now you and i may say i wouldn't want to
live that life i mean
what are you talking about i don't want
to be controlled by other people i don't
want to be naive where i just
look at the media oh okay vote this way
okay okay do this oh they're the bad
people oh you're right they're the bad
people i don't want to be that person
but there's a part of your life you know
is that the life kind of i want to live
am i going to miss the freedom the
special small things that used to make
me be happy now i can't even enjoy the
small stuff that i used to
do you ever catch yourself asking oh
man maybe i'm in too deep of being this
worried genius and i've lost a bit of my
oh yes absolutely simple well i
certainly experienced that
when my health broke down and the reason
for that was that i
i not only did i get sick my life fell
apart because i couldn't do anything
that i used to be able to do
i couldn't listen to music i couldn't
read i couldn't write
i couldn't think i i i couldn't do any
of the because
everything that i had done was really
was
complex and difficult all the things
that i engaged in
and what i did realize was that that
left me vulnerable on a certain front
because if i lost my
if i wasn't at in peak peak health let's
say
i wouldn't be able to do those things
and so i mean
that's why i'm walking now for example
you know i said i walk six miles a day
and i do that every day
and it's very simple and i've played a
lot of ping pong and i've always liked
that but i never played that much but i
liked that and
there there is some utility in having
things around that are rewarding and
good for you that are less complex
um i would say though that with regards
to the conflict between
let's say you know miserable wisdom
and happy ignorance is that there's
there's different forms of rewards to be
found in different places
you know you can think about this even
in terms of personality
one major personality dimension is
extraversion and the reason for that is
that
we have a pleasure circuit and how
active that is
varies between people that's what causes
variation in extroversion and
we generally equate happiness with the
activation of the circuitry that's
associated with extroversion
and drugs like cocaine and amphetamines
activate that circuit
but there's another personality
dimension which is openness
and openness is the creativity dimension
and there's pleasure to be derived from
that as well and then so that's
philosophical exploration and and
literary experience and
i suppose when you go to a movie you
experience a blend of those two
things especially if it's a rather
complex movie so there's different forms
of
engagement or pleasure to be found and
some of them are more akin to happiness
and some of them are more akin to
to meaning and sometimes they come into
conflict but but i think
all things considered they they work
best when they're when they're working
together
and i i do strive diligently to
re and i think that this has really been
brought home to me
you know look i couldn't sit down i
literally couldn't sit down for almost a
year
and i so i lost the ability to sit down
i had fantasies
for hours of being able to sit by a
fireplace and just
not move because i had this condition
called akathesia
which is
i learned how how valuable it is to be
able to sit down and now when i sit down
and nothing is happening i i'm taking
stock of that and noticing what an
unbelievable gift that is and it is
really useful to
maintain your ability to see what you
have that you've
taken for granted because you can lose
you can lose everything
you can lose things you don't even know
you have i have no idea that you could
ever lose the ability just to sit down
but you can uh i wouldn't recommend it
so i'm more appreciative i would say of
of simpler things than i was
i'm more appreciative of other people
than i was
i'm probably more grateful all things
considered than i was
and hopefully that will continue
developing
i have no contempt for happiness you
know i i tell people don't pursue
happiness pursue
meaning and i think that's true but if
happiness comes along
it should be welcomed and if you're ever
somewhere where that's happening
you should notice it and and be grateful
for it and enjoy it and
that's for sure yeah do you think
sometimes
uh the world sets an expectation of who
you are and your constant compliments oh
my gosh jordan let me tell you you
changed my life oh my gosh jordan
you don't even know what your book did
to me oh my gosh oh my gosh oh you have
no idea
because of you i'm doing that because of
you my marriage work because of you i
have better relation my dad because of
you i'm doing better my mom because of
you
because of you because of you sometimes
that
because of you it's a little too much
burden of because of you it's like dude
because of me don't do [ __ ] like because
of me just let me be free for once like
because of you like
maybe i don't want you to say because of
you look go go live your life
you because of you you made the decision
i'm just writing the book do you ever
feel like
you don't want that standard and
expectation of
you know putting you on the pedestal
here and then
you have to almost walk on water where
you're not free do you ever feel
that kind of an obligation or no that's
not even something that crosses your
mind i feel that obligation all the time
got it and i i have people around right
from the beginning of all this
i've i've talked to my friends and my
family all the time about what i'm doing
so that i don't
make a mistake you know so that we're
trying to stop me from making a mistake
so but i also especially when i'm
talking to people one-on-one i don't
want
see if you're a clinical psychologist
you don't want to steal people's
accomplishments from them which is
partly why you don't
you don't give advice exactly so maybe
someone is trying to decide whether they
should get married
and maybe you have an opinion but
probably you shouldn't
because as a psychologist let's say
because
except perhaps in extreme cases um
the person has to discover that what
they need to do for themselves
so that they can discover it again in
the future so that they can learn to
discover things for themselves
and you don't want to give advice
because then if they do something good
you can take credit for it
and i i don't want to take credit for
for
um the accomplishments that people make
as a consequence of
um what would you say putting the ideas
they encounter in my books
into practice they put them into
practice and good for them
and so when i meet people in the street
that's what i tell them you know it's
like
okay you did this this specific thing
good for you
and you know i provided some impetus and
i'm happy about that and pleased to to
do that but
i certainly don't want the credit and
but i certainly i do feel the obligation
i think it is part of what made me ill
i think it is because
you know as a psychologist i dealt with
people's innermost secrets for
decades and but it was kind of limited
right it was 13 people or so a week
maybe up to 20 which is still quite a
few people but it's not
it's not an inordinate number of people
it's a bounded
number of people and and then i had my
other work that i could
escape into let's say and and i wasn't
carrying it with me
the burden of of of of the lives of the
people that i was intertwined with
but then all of a sudden i started to
experience
that the longing i suppose in some sense
on a much greater scale
and that that's been
difficult to digest the misery
and and that that's so common
in people's lives and but even worse
than that that the degree to which it
requires
almost nothing to rectify it in an
important way
you know people there's many many people
who are
starving for a word of encouragement and
if you provide that
they they run with it and but that and
that's great but it also reveals this
this terrible unnecessary lack it's like
well why weren't they encouraged to
begin with
you know it and and that's a deep hole
to fall down
and you know because you can never stop
answering that question once you start
asking it
and you know it has something to do with
with the fundamental
difficulty that everyone who's human has
in
valuing their own existence because of
its
imperfections and and finitude and
it's a very complex question and then to
see that
played out thousands of times
these brief encounters i have with
people they're very intense
you know people tell me things in those
encounters that they don't tell anyone
else or or they tell very few people or
maybe they've never told anyone in their
life and
i can see too this young man stopped me
on the street the other day and he was
he was looking a bit beat up and he came
up and he said
he was very shy and he said well you
you know your lectures have been very
helpful and i said i asked him what his
name was and that usually helps people
set
set them at ease and then i said well
what what helped you
and he's he he was quite hesitant he
didn't exactly know how to formulate
what he was doing but i could see that
he was very scared to say
anything that he had done well
because his experience had been that
he'd never been
encouraged when he did something well
and so you know you can really punish
someone if they come up to you and say
they did something good that was
actually good and then you punish them
or ignore them
it really hurts them and that happens to
children all the time
and it certainly had happened to this
young man so he's very hesitant
to tell me what he had done that was
good and you know he told me and i
listened and i said look this is
as far as i'm concerned that what you
did was really good and he just lit up
you know it was and that's great that he
lit up but it's
terrible that it hadn't happened to him
before
it's really terrible and then i see this
tied in with like
a cultural pathology that a variety of
cultural pathologies that
are manifesting themselves at the
current time you know the idea that
organized masculine activity is by
definition some kind of
power centered tyranny and the corollary
that
any sort of ambition on the part of
young men to
well any ambition towards achievement is
somehow
integrally tied up with tyrannical power
it's so demoralizing for young men they
don't know how to defend themselves
against that and
the idea and you know it's often leveled
the accusation is often leveled by
people who've never had a relationship
with a male
in their life that was actually
fulfilling and worthwhile
and then that all plays out in the
public domain it's really awful to see
and i can see it
so it's hard it's hard it's hard to see
that
i mean i'm thrilled that i am in a
position to do something about it it's
so
so great you know that's something else
i can tell people now too you know
because you say well what should you do
with your life
and like i cannot i've seen
people who've accomplished anything that
you can imagine
in terms of accomplishments and i can
say
clearly that i've never seen anything as
rewarding as
the consequences of forthright speech
the opportunity to be of genuine
service to other people um
there's way more reward in that than
in in any of the things that people
chase in a more finite and limited way
you know jordan when you're going
through that
phase normally for a person to
come out of a place we are that we've
never been before we need some kind of a
source of inspiration
right so yeah and and we like to find
someone to say well that's my hero like
i have a painting in my office called
dead mentors it's me in the painting
with eight other characters
in a vault we're having a conversation
it's a debate between two books
communist manifesto and atlas shrugs so
it's a discourse they're having a debate
having a discourse it's very interesting
characters
but you can tap into somebody you're
like okay i can tackle who are the
characters who are the characters in the
painting
let me i just moved to florida so so i
got john f kennedy
i got einstein i got the shop iran
lincoln mlk tupac ironton cena
uh milton friedman and uh one other
character i'm forgetting
great so so that's so good because look
and you can surround yourself with
these these great minds and and you can
you can you can you can what would you
say in some sense you can choose them as
your peers
voluntarily dead or not right it's a
form of ancestor worship in some sense
and i mean that
in the most i mean that in the deep
sense and
you can do that's one of the advantages
of that is education as far as i'm
concerned is
pick your peers and and yeah
and this instinct we have to find
someone to admire that's the deepest of
religious instincts and it's
unbelievably deep in human beings
and you know and and we have this
mimicry this capacity for mimicry that's
that's
an integral part of our cognitive
architecture and
uh it's the precursor to thought and we
do identify
you know you notice you notice you
admire someone that is the instinct
to mimic because to admire is then to
want to be
that and that's the action of the moral
instinct it finds a target in the world
and says well i could be like that
but at first it says this person is
attractive or this person is compelling
it grabs you
it grabs you and that's the instinct for
further developments very positive thing
it can be a very positive thing who'd
you tap into
was it a biblical figure was it a
philosopher was it a leader
was it a political leader when you were
going through your moment the last 12
months who were you saying at least
he overcame it i can here's what he went
through was worse here's what
was there anybody you would go to well
there has been throughout my life
all sorts of of intellectual figures
figures from my own life as well i found
many things about my father
extremely admirable and and still do my
mother as well and so i was fortunate to
have people in my immediate environment
who
played that role for me and that that's
a huge gift
i have all sorts of intellectual idols
um
i would say and there are people whose
work i've read deeply and that's been
extremely useful to me
um and then that shades into the
consideration of religious figures at
at some point um so and i've spent a lot
of time studying religious thinking and
trying to i mean what religious thinking
isn't in some sense is the
collective attempt to specify the ideal
for
for mimicry so you imagine that imagine
that
you know you you have those eight
figures in your painting
so imagine there's something about each
of those people that you found
compelling and admirable
so then imagine that you could abstract
out from that
what was compelling and admirable and
make one person out of that that was
sort of the union of all those eight
it was everything good about those eight
people brought into one
person well that's that's approaching a
divine figure
and and and when you hear christian
statements for example like christ
is the king of kings that actually means
something technical from a psychological
perspective
what it means is that and i'm not
speaking in religious terms here
precisely although it shades into the
religious is that
a religious ideal is in fact
the abstracted representation of what is
admirable
as such and it's a it's extremely
useful to have that made into an
abstraction to some degree too because
it also means that you then have
something that you're responsible to
so let's say you and you've done this
with your painting
you have these eight people who you're
now um
what what would you say you're
responsible to them you're accountable
to them
you're accountable to their spirit and
so
now your conscience can speak with their
collective voice and it can tell you
when you're less than you could be
and then you can use that to guide you
to manifest that spirit that's
embodied in those eight people and
that's a pathway to further growth
and and it's something that we're we're
hypothetically in all of our
conversations when we're demanding from
one another that we respond properly
we're trying to evoke that ideal from
ourselves and from other people
we're constantly doing that that's
partly why i love podcasts because that
can really happen in real time
like i just released a conversation with
jocko willing today where i think that
happened
for much of the conversation and
you know as i get healthier i'm hoping
that will work better
and to the degree that we're doing the
right thing at the moment
you know we're doing our best to
manifest that abstracted ideal
and the other thing that's so remarkable
about that is that as long as we do it
the better we do it the more compelling
we're going to find the conversation the
time will disappear
we'll get absorbed into the conversation
and we'll walk away thinking i don't
know what was happening but that was
worth doing
and and you get that you get
there as far as i'm concerned you get
there with
with truth that's the pathway
spoken truth jordan who who are those
names you said mom dad who else are some
of those names
that you uh you go to well you and carl
jung was an
unbelievably profound influence on me
almost all the major psychotherapists i
read them deeply
carl rogers was real useful to me
abraham maslow
freud i read a lot of freud uh and then
there's
alexander schulze nitchen was a huge
influence friedrich nietzsche i read
most of his major works when i was young
um and then a a large number of
scientists uh jeffrey gray who's a
neuroscientist
i i i uh what would you say
clawed my way through his work which is
very very dense it was extremely useful
he was a good model as a scientist my
mentor at mcgill robert peel was
someone who who taught me a lot about
administration and about
uh giving credit where credit is due and
um being comfortable in your own domain
of competence like
bob who i am still in regular contact
with
bob and i had different skills and he
was able to value my skills without ever
feeling intimidated
and and i could do the same with his
skills and that made our partnership
extremely productive and so that was
very useful um uh
are you are you familiar with uh robert
green's work 40 laws of power art of
seduction 33 strategies of war
only only as names i haven't read i
haven't read his books
okay got it he he wrote a book his last
book was
laws of human nature and right after he
finished his book
he had a stroke and not a not the best
kind of stroke he had a terrible stroke
and his wife had to come and pick him up
and he couldn't walk
we did an interview one time with him we
had to push him in the wheelchair to get
him it took 30 minutes before we got
ready to go through it
and i i asked him a question i said how
timely the fact and every time he was
working on the book i said how you doing
he says you know what i'm sick and my
mom's calling me telling me how's the
book i said mom stop asking me about the
book
i don't want to tell you about the book
you know the process of writing a book
for somebody as
technical as you you're not writing a
book like here's the
you know seven keys to success
work hard you know all this other stuff
that maybe you see you know you
you kind of your your brain is uh you
know
trying to get everything to be perfect i
remember one time i asked you a question
about how do you research and how do you
write
you said you're right then you rewrite
then you rewrite i'm like how many times
do you write so so many times i have to
write something on and rewrite i'm like
wow very detailed a process you go
through
how heavy is it on you when you write a
book i i think
the only thing i've done that's as hard
as writing is clinical work
it's the only thing that requires as
much attention it's unbelievably
engaging but it's unbelievably difficult
and well i suppose to some degree it's
as difficult as you make it but
i'm always trying to answer questions
that i genuinely have and i'm really
trying to answer them
and i i i also so
i have a writing guide online for people
who might be interested
you can find that and it it's an
actually step-by-step
guide through what you actually have to
do if you want to write
it's not just hints about what
constitutes good writing it's a practice
manual
we're building a piece of software
called essay app
that's designed to help people write
better and therefore think better
but i mean i have an analytic approach
to writing to some degree
because i i i can write but i also know
what i'm doing when i'm writing so
imagine that a piece of work can be
analyzed
at multiple levels simultaneously did
you did you select the right word
did you select the right phrase did you
organize the phrases into the proper
sentences are
is each sentence as tightly written
and carefully argued as it possibly
could be are the sentences arranged
properly in each paragraph
are the paragraphs arranged properly in
each section are the sections arranged
properly within each larger unit does it
cohere as a whole
is it appropriate for the time and the
place and the audience
do the sentences sound poetic when you
read them aloud do they have a rhythm
i'm trying to answer all those questions
not at the same time but i
i try to answer all those questions with
every single word i write
and i would say i write every sentence
at least 10 or 15 times
and i mean literally i take the sentence
i put it on a separate page
and then i rewrite it multiple times and
then i pick the best sentence
and then when i do paragraph editing i
take the paragraph
put it on a separate page break it into
its sentences
rearrange the sentences in in multiple
variants and then select the one that
works the best and i do that over and
over
and so that well that's
that's so it's demanding because you the
the more you get every single one of
those things right the more impact the
work has
the clearer you've made the problem and
the more also you
the other thing each like these are
books that i've written even though
there are collections of essays but
each essay stands in relationship to the
other essays
they're not independent units they they
they each add something to every other
chapter and so there's a meta meaning
that emerges that's a consequence of the
relationship between the essays and
i'm thinking about that as well when i'm
writing and trying to organize the
essays and
and it's great for clarity of thought
and i one of the things i loved about my
conversation with jocko willink
um because he's this very masculine
very tough man very admirable person but
you know on the physical end of things
at least that's what you'd think but
he got an english degree after he was a
navy seal
and he did a 20-minute spontaneous
proclamation about the unbelievable
value of literacy
to him practically speaking you know he
said well
he has to write out military strategy
he has to decode orders coming from
above he has to write up commendations
for
his men he has to produce battlefield
reports
he said he's noah he's nowhere at all as
powerful as he could be without
being literate and literacy is the key
to
competence in a way that is just not
properly communicated to young people
you're deadly if you're literate at
everything
and it's because you you can think and
you can speak
i mean what do you have that's more than
that
not there's nothing we have that's more
than that and writing
sharpens your thinking we're excited
about this app i'm you know i
i i'm really it would be wonderful if we
managed to contribute something to
make the process of writing work better
for people so that they can think more
clearly
so what it does is it helps break down
what you're writing into all these
different
uh sections so there's like a sentence
level of analysis and a paragraph level
of analysis and so forth so that
you can concentrate on one part of the
writing process at
at once instead of trying to solve all
the problems at the same time
which is so complex it'll just bring you
to a halt so for example you should
write a really bad first draft
with no care about grammar or any of
that just get your ideas down doesn't
even matter the order but get the first
draft down
and then so you don't add it to begin
with you produce and once you've
produced you can add it and then re-edit
and re-add it and so forth but
just separating those two things is
extremely useful it's interesting you
say this because uh
what's the story about you when a guy on
quora asked you a question about
rules of life and you came up with 42
you posted it there and you got more
shares and
conversation and it was you know talked
about and that kind of led to the whole
idea about
your 12 rules of life and beyond you
know yeah look what came out of that
yeah yeah it's it's staggering you know
i mean
i spent about well i spent about half an
hour writing those but i spent like
god only knows how long sure doing the
background thinking that
enabled me to write them and yeah the
the consequences of that were just
powerful creative thinking just led to
uh what it led to today
so joan let's talk about some of the
stuff current events on what's going on
today
um so you're not around you you know
you're
you're you're recovering you're going
through what you're going through you're
in russia you're in florida
news comes out trump's being banned
permanently by twitter
jack dorsey announces that then it's
facebook they don't say permanently
but they're kind of taking them down for
now youtube says for now but we'll see
what's going to happen in the future the
only one that used
the award permanently is dorsey
on twitter okay and you know
you've been in the space of creating
content for a while some of the stuff
you've said it's upset
a few people you had one legendary
interview
that uh uh did very well where
the lady was trying to spook you and
then next thing you know it backfired on
her and
you asked her a question and he said
gotcha and that kind of led to you know
all these different things and
even some of the things that was going
on in toronto when you were a teacher
there were some challenges there were
trans
gender whatever was going on and you
came out and spoke up and there was some
kind of a
a debate that came up from that but uh
trump being banned alex jones a few
years ago
twitter youtube infowars they're coming
after they're doing this
okay what was your reaction when you
heard about the fact that the 45th
president united states is being
banned permanently in a very powerful
virtual government called twitter
well i thought that the
companies who are doing
such things have no idea what
responsibility they're taking on
because now they've announced their
willingness or maybe even their
responsibility depending on how you look
at it
to police the content of what's being
exchanged on their
networks well that's a
rabbit hole that you in all likelihood
don't want to go down
so
you see attempts to censor emerging
quite constantly now
and it's it's it's very dangerous
it's very dangerous it's very upsetting
that this happened
to the president to an elected president
what's what's the
you're you're someone who's well read
you've read history what has been the
consequences
of silencing someone
that has a big following who ends up
paying a price
long term is it the individual that
silence a trump is it his following or
is it the silencer
who eventually created more enemies that
backfired on them long term who ends up
losing long term
well everybody does i would say because
the classic defense for
free speech is that you know if you
limit someone's free speech not only do
you limit the rights of the person who's
speaking but you limit the rights of
those who could have heard
and it seems to me that
people i believe that people have the
intelligence to make up their own minds
and that they should have
the information presented presented to
them my experience has been that
people have people are far more
intelligent
and perspicacious than than we generally
assume
they they come to the right conclusions
the right conclusions who's to say but
you know i i don't think there's
anything more important than freedom of
speech
so maybe maybe maybe let me ask the
question a different way let me ask a
question a different way so
we have a lot of different issues that's
being talked about right now things are
interchanged and obviously we've kind of
known what direction we're going
we have joe biden as our president i'd
rather hear what trump is thinking
than not i'd rather know than not
i'd rather see what's happening out in
the public than not
i don't know what's going on underground
now
i don't i have no idea and i know that
and no one knows what the impact of this
has been on
all the people who supported trump what
are they supposed to conclude precisely
from this
i'd rather these things were out in the
open
i don't think that these companies had
the right to do what they did
they had the right legally they had the
right um
obviously because they did it and they
got away with it um
but you know there's a technological
problem at the bottom of it too we have
all these new communication technologies
and we don't really know what the rules
are
none of us do including the people who
run the these
social networks it's not like they
understand what they've created
how could you no one can understand them
what you've created
you know i was just talking to michael
malus the other day about 4chan
4chan had some effect on the hillary
trump election
it's possible that 4chan tilted the
election in favor of trump because the
margin was pretty small but in any case
4chan in some sense doesn't even exist
there's no centralized authority there's
no
administrative bureaucracy every you can
post there anonymously and
your posts disappear but we don't know
anything about
how to regulate uh an at a
communications apparatus like this
or even how it should be regulated in
principle or even what it does
or what it is and so i have some
sympathy
for the giant media corporations because
they're dealing with intractable
problems but
i still believe that the censorship road
is
well it's likely to lead to a place that
people
don't want to go
so which is what
well part of its second guessing you
know
you you want to be able to say what you
think and if you have the voice of a
hypothetical sensor in your head i mean
i've experienced this already i've had
guests on my show like abigail schreier
who wrote a book on
um on on the trans
issue trend surgery in particular
gender reassignment surgery and i was
very
nervous about having the discussion
so there was the little sensor inside my
head already
operating and when enough sensors
operate in your head then you can no
longer think and if you can no longer
think
well then you can't see and you're blind
and you stumble into holes and
and everyone stumbles into holes and
that's not good
and you know it i've said over and over
that if you're discussing something that
matters the probability that you're
going to offend someone is
rises to virtual certainty if if
the discussion you're having about an
important issue
is not
isn't of sufficient potency to offend
someone then you're not saying anything
at all
well then how many people should you
offend or can you offend before you're
properly banned you know you can say
well a line was crossed because the
president of the united states
fomented armed insurrection well
had the situation be not clear he would
have been impeached
so there's ambiguity around the
circumstances well a line was obviously
crossed well what line
exactly and who's going to decide when
it's crossed
exactly and this is very troublesome but
it's a problem we all have like it's not
a problem
in some sense it's not a problem that
jack
dorsey has or or uh or mark zuckerberg
they're they're facing the same set of
issues that the rest of it are facing i
mean they have
more authority over their platform
obviously but
it's not like there's a bunch of us out
here who have the answer and
they could just come asking we're all
facing this
mystery which is what our technological
transformation of our means of
communication what it means
and what we should do with it
it's very complicated what should we do
with what should i mean you're trying to
answer that question all the time
what should you do with your podcast
what should you do with your youtube
channel
it's complicated you have an unlimited
bandwidth
and you have the opportunity to do every
anything you want and share it with
hundreds of thousands of people
okay what should you do you know you
have enough money
and so you know because one simple
answer to a problem is well i'll do what
makes money it's like okay well now you
have the money okay now what you should
what should you do
well it's complicated it's really
complicated
and and so we need to talk about what we
should do
and we are in fact doing that so that's
right it seems to be working
so so so let me ask you this today you
know i feel like every decade every era
there's different set of problems i
don't even think it's an era i think
it's decade like
you know maybe oh sorry i'd like to sit
down with trump and
and talk to him like i'm talking to you
because i don't know i'd like to know
what he's thinking
and i think everybody should know what
he's thinking and it isn't obvious to me
that i could do a youtube interview with
donald trump and have it aired
and that seems to be a problem because
don't we want to know what he's thinking
don't we want everyone else to see what
he's thinking
you know whether you're a foe or a
friend well we should know
and i've been inviting politicians onto
my show it's like come on for two hours
and
let's have a talk it's not sound bites
it's
it's an opportunity for you to reveal
yourself
can you will you what happens when you
do
has your camp ever reached out to him or
no not specifically to trump i've been
reaching out to other politicians i have
um
um mike lee senator mike lee from utah i
think we're releasing that next week and
he's the most conservative senator and
he comes about his conservatism honestly
he's a senator from utah
and you know he acquitted himself rather
well over the two
two and a half hour period i'd like to
see every politician do that
that who are you like there's enough
time there for for everyone to reveal
their hand
and i think that's to in everyone's best
interest and i believe there'll be more
uh political leaders on my show in the
future that's we're pushing in that
direction as hard as we can
many many politicians are unbelievably
leery of
of long format they don't understand it
they don't understand
youtube they don't understand podcasts
they're still stuck in 1970
technologically speaking and
you know they're worried about
misstepping but you can misstep by
omission too and
youtube the long-form podcasts allow
politicians to bypass
the gatekeepers the media gatekeepers
completely and just talk to their
constituents
well that'll revolutionize politics if
people actually start to engage in it
i think
at least it has the possibility of that
happening
uh if you were to sit down with trump
what would you be asking him right now
i'd ask him what he thought about what
happened on
in in in the capital in the day of the
riots
what's his story about that he's
addressed that
what did he think yeah but i'd like to
i'd like to
go go after it in depth um
i'd i'd like to ask him about um
who he thinks think he thought he
appealed to and why and
and what he did that he thought worked
um i'd like to ask him what he thinks
about the
the accusations of that pertain to his
reprehensibility
his character and and what he thinks
about that and how
how he would respond to that but i'd
like to find out like
i wouldn't be interested in hurling
accusations or or
i'd like to find out what he thinks
because god wouldn't he like to know
what trump thinks
i'd love to know what he thinks we need
to know because
half the population voted for him why do
you think
why do you think opposition doesn't want
you to know what he's thinking what what
do you think they're scared of
i think they're scared of all sorts of
things i think they they're they're
they're scared of the possibility that
he has
uh the power of a demagogue that he's a
a populist that that he could harness
the crowd for nefarious ends
uh they're concerned about his
respect for democratic norms and and the
standard
um what would you say his respect for
the
authorities of the state you know they
view him as a
as a muslim in the making let's say and
so
that's their fear and you know there are
mussolini's in the making and
trump was a populist and so that's where
that fear comes from
um there's also fear of course because
some people think one way politically
and a lot of this is temperamentally
based and other people think another way
and it's hard
for them to communicate across the
divide
um so that's some of the fear
but you know it has to be addressed
because you you in the u.s there's this
problem that 50
of this problem this situation 50 of the
people voted for trump
that can't just be swept under the rug
you can't sweep something like that
under the rug
like at all and so what
what's going to be the consequence of of
stopping him from speaking
why would you think that all the
consequences of that are going to be
good
i don't think they're going to be good i
mean certainly a large part of the
american
population felt like they were
punched by the large media companies
the large social media companies you
know because they were affiliated with
trump and all of a sudden he was
silenced so all those people feel that
they've been silenced
well they have been well you might say
well those are precisely the people who
should be silenced just really is that
what you think
you think 25 of your population should
be silenced
do you what does that say about you
and what are you going to do with those
25 you have to live with them
christ you're probably related to a
bunch of them
so it's not a good solution
i don't think does it backfire on them
it always backfires i mean if you assume
that
how could it not backfire if if if
investigating something complex is
worthwhile how could
failure to investigate it not backfire
it's not like the conditions that gave
rise to trump
are likely to magically vanish you know
and now it's possible that if biden does
a credible job
or even a great job and i hope he does
that
that political temperature will lower
and and this will become a non-issue
essentially
if we're lucky it'll just fade away and
trump is getting old too you know
there is that blunt fact
and so maybe we'll just move on to other
things and it's possible that that might
be
the outcome we should hope for but
what do you mean well that we get on
with the next thing
you know do you think that's a good
thing because
well i don't know i don't know i really
don't know i mean i wish biden well i
hope he does a good job because
he's your president and wouldn't it be
good if he did a good job you guys need
a good president
um and maybe there are things that we
should be
focusing our attention on right here and
now
yeah i just think i think you know like
the topic of jfk assassination right so
the jfk assassination topic till today
people want to figure out what really
happened the debate still steers it up
every
november 22nd people oh well this is
what happened no that's what happened oh
this is what happened no it's really
this is what happened no not now we have
the real story
movie after movie after movie after
movie after movie
we don't have we don't have any way to
go get a hundred percent
definite you know definitive answer
everything's going to be 82
92 63 we're not going to get 100 right
trump is around right now there's a lot
to learn about what happened
and i'm not even i'm not making it like
when you're saying let's move on i don't
mean move on like you know well he's
going to die and move on
not talking about that i'm talking i
don't i don't think things should be
brushed under the rug and i
i don't think that usually works i've
never seen it work yeah i think there's
so much market research right now for us
to find out about what's gonna happen
if we don't figure out what really
happened and the amount of power
clarence thomas today came out and he
said he made some comments about section
230 i don't know if you read that or i
don't know if you heard about that
uh what he thinks about section 230 you
know the common carrier rules on twitter
you may want to look it up because he
kind of commented on it today
and it's creating frenzy when dennis
prager and i who's a good friend of mine
i think he's also a good friend of yours
when you're done under a fair bit of
censorship pressure which i'm
happy about yes and you know his wife
sue is a lawyer
when they went up against youtube they
ended up
losing because the court finally said
no they have the right because the same
rules that apply to government doesn't
apply to a private company because if
they don't want to
a you know they want to do whatever you
want to they can do it they're not a
government they don't
they don't go based on the same rules of
freedom of speech they can do whatever
they want to do
the government can't the government's
got to allow you to speak right and so
i was speaking to a guy this last week
who bought metacogan you may not know
merkovan i don't know if you've been
following nfts or not meadowcoven is the
guy
who's a crypto billionaire who bought
people's every days for 69.3 million
dollars and we're talking about
where do you live right now since i live
in um i live in uh
uh uh singapore so why do you live in
singapore you're indian why why
singapore why not us he says well i
lived in canada
i lived in a few different places uk but
i chose singapore i said why not u.s he
smiles and he's not a
energetic speaker like the way he's not
like that he's very you know
calm the way he speaks he says i didn't
want to go to u.s because u.s
it's all they have fingerprints on you
and it's like a web they're going to
figure out a way to get the taxes on he
says listen i live in singapore
zero in capital gains taxes i said zero
is a zero
you don't pay any capital so why would
you pay capital gains taxes you know our
ordinary income is 10 or 20
no regulation i don't have to you know
tell the government what i have and hey
here's how much money i have i don't
want to tell anybody what i have so i
can keep it to myself it's my business
if i go to u.s
i have to tell everybody what i have et
cetera et cetera
and i'm sitting i'm like singapore okay
interesting you know trump here
he's going through what he's going
through this guy's over here living free
and then he says you have to realize
that nowadays twitter facebook youtube
these things are virtual governments
and they are controlling america america
is no longer what america used to be
america's a whole different america so
for us if we don't get to the bottom of
this today
i think a lot of people who have a voice
are going to be bullied for decades
and i think we got to get to the bottom
of it while you know we have the ability
to sit down and trump's got to be
interviewed properly where someone's
going to learn the other day his
daughter-in-law interviewed him
facebook took the interview down i don't
know if you saw that when the you know
laura does the interview
so it would be very interesting to see
someone like yourself interview him
yeah well i'd i would love to do that i
think it would be
well how could it fail to be anything
but fascinating at least for me
hopefully for people who are viewing it
you know it's a complicated it's a
complicated problem
but my sense is that
you tell people what's going on and let
them figure it out
you can't hide it anyways if it's real
you can't hide it it comes out
you can't hide reality it always comes
out
and usually if you try to hide it it
comes out in a much worse form
that that's my experience as a
psychologist i've never seen anyone
successfully hide anything in their life
not really it leaks out in all sorts of
ways
they don't necessarily even make the
connection but but
they can discover the connection later
and be very sad about it
how much of this has to do with your
book beyond order rule number six
abandon ideology
think that's something that we are
struggling with as a nation especially
america
well people struggle with it all the
time because we're attracted to
oversimplifications and and
it's no wonder because the world the
complexity of the world is daunting and
if you have a ready-made answer for for
almost everything then
that simplifies the the landscape
substantially
some of it's just a matter of not being
taught to think well
you know one of the things you learn if
you're a social scientist a research
scientist is that you generate if you're
looking at a complex phenomenon like
male aggression let's say
well what causes male aggression well
the first thing you do is generate like
20 possible reasons you don't limit
yourself to the one you like
you know like maybe i'm not that happy
about tv and so i think well tv
violence probably makes men more violent
it doesn't by the way there's there's
very little evidence that it does
there's quite a lot of evidence that it
doesn't
video games because i don't i think
they're a waste of time so they probably
increase male aggressions like well no
they don't
as it turns out um alcohol that
definitely increases aggression male
aggression and female aggression for
that matter so alcohol is a major
contributor
is it sociological is it cultural do you
learn it is it biological
you generate all sorts of potential
reasons
and you might also say well many of
those reasons apply not just
one and then you test them and then and
then the next thing you do maybe you
say well i want to decrease male
aggression
well you don't assume that you know how
to do that and that if you do what you
think you know that it will work
that's all ideological thinking the real
world is
way too complicated to be uh
pushed around by that kind of thinking
and
poverty well what causes poverty well
what do you mean by poverty well you
could you could think for
two weeks about what poverty is and you
still wouldn't come to the end of it
do you mean low ed lower education do
you mean lower intelligence do you mean
lower conscientiousness do you mean drug
and alcohol abuse
do you mean lack of money do you mean
absolute poverty do you mean relative
poverty
you calculate that neighborhood by
neighborhood or state by state um
do you mean poverty of hope do you mean
lack of plan for the future
et cetera et cetera and all of those
questions so you decompose so you think
well
poverty is caused by lack of money it's
like really that's your that's your
theory is it
well you know it's not good enough that
theory it's not even close
and so part of that chapter is just
an attempt to explain that most things
that are
truly problematic are so complex that no
ideological solution
can possibly suffice it's just not a
good way to go about the problem
and then there's the other problem too
which is that well
one of the terrible temptations of an
ideology is that once you parse out the
world and have your reasons
why problems exist so let's say poverty
exists because of
capitalism which is a completely idiotic
theory i mean
poverty exists because people are born
with nothing
and it's hard to acquire goods so that
the default state is poverty so it's not
caused by any sociological system so
it's
it's foolish to begin with but let's
assume that you think that
poverty or at least relative poverty is
caused by capitalism
well then you have a convenient enemy
you know it's everyone who's a
successful capitalist is now responsible
for poverty and
then they're bad and you're good and
that's
unearned moral virtue and that's
unbelievably attractive to to
acquire unearned moral virtue
you know or so or maybe you're maybe
you're uh
you're someone who's inherited your
wealth and and then you think everyone
who's poor
is just lazy and if they'd get up off
their asses and get a job that would
solve the problem it's like well that's
convenient for you but it's a
very shallow analysis of the problem
so it's not helpful to think that way
unless what you want to do is not
think which is which is kind of where we
are today though if you think about it
you know the the less we think the more
we can be controlled
it just just a crazy question for you
strategically i don't know if you think
and say
as a you know you know how jaco
likes to read about war and his main you
know
that's his interest because of what he
did he's a pretty deep thinker his mind
goes in very deep places
on topics but if you were to think like
a strategist for a moment here
what are what are democrats not the left
what are democrats trying to accomplish
we know what the left is trying to
accomplish like i'm not talking about
aoc sanders
what are democrats trying to accomplish
right now like what's their moment
look if you look at jonathan heights
research one of the things you conclude
a psychologist from
from new york university um he's looked
at temperamental predictors of
political belief okay and the liberal
types the leftists are concerned
with fairness broadly speaking it's what
they orient themselves around and a fair
bit of that seems temperamental
the conservative types this isn't
heights uh taxonomy precisely but the
conservative types are more concerned
with order
and and justice and tradition
and those are all values you know like
there's utility in fairness there's
utility and justice there's utility in
tradition
while the devil's in the details but
broadly speaking it's the issue of
fairness so
for example i was talking to russell
brand last week and he's a lefty by
temperament
and intellectual proclivity and i told
him about all this research showing that
if you look around the world that um the
incidence of absolute privation
has plummeted dramatically in the last
40 years
well really the last 200 but it's really
been decreasing over the last
40 since the soviet union collapsed um
so for for example now the typical
sub-saharan
african has access to more calories than
you need to
to maintain yourself so enough calories
but also as many calories as the typical
person
in portugal had in the 1960s so in the
poorest area
on earth there's enough food
no one starves anymore except for
reasons of distribution and and
political oppression
it's great that that's the case so
absolute privation has decreased
substantially and you think while people
could be partying in the streets because
of that and there's reasons that they
aren't and but you know russell
russell's concern immediately was well
what about relative deprivation
you know on average people are much
better but there's a huge range
so some people are way better off than
others and some people are in a state of
you know very they're just barely
clinging on to the edge of the world and
of course that's a problem
so you could imagine that the benevolent
conservative types
it's just an example are pushing
to have absolute privation decreased and
they're saying well look how well that's
going but the lefty types think yeah but
you still got a distribution problem
and it's true and relative poverty
absolute poverty is a catastrophe but
relative poverty is
also a problem look when you're walking
down the street you're a wealthy man
you're not happy to see homeless people
so you know i've not met anyone who
would say well
who cares about homeless people it's
like that's the price we pay for
progress or whatever no
if you could wave a magic wand and all
of a sudden things would be different
well then the homeless people would have
enough of whatever it
is that they need but you don't know how
to do that and it isn't as simple as
well they need more money
well so the lefties are more concerned
about fairness and
there's there's a point to be made there
no fairness isn't everything and
that's the counter-argument so
so what are they up to well then i would
say what are the democrats up to and i
would say they don't actually know
because one of the things i was stunned
by when i
went to washington and and i spent some
time there talking to congress people
and
watching and i was stunned there's
virtually no formal policy making
apparatus in the
in the political parties in the u.s so
what are they up to
they don't know and they don't know how
to communicate whatever it is they're up
to and so what happens this is what's
happened to the democrats and
conservatives who are listening should
know this is that most of the democrats
are moderate centrists the overwhelming
majority of them are moderate centrists
and
most of them moderate centrist
conservatives would be perfectly happy
with if they had a discussion with them
you know would there be some minor
sticking points but
they'd share much more in common than
they would have in variants
well so why do the radicals have such a
disproportionate voice and
the answer is simple they have a
compelling story and the centrists
don't and then you might say well that's
the centrist democrats problems it's
like okay
what's the centrist republican story
they don't have one either
and no real apparatus for generating one
it's stunning how much of a lack there
is in that particular domain
i mean formally speaking no policy
generating
organization and no communication
strategy i couldn't believe it
it's unbelievable where would you put
trump at
trump's an anomaly he's his own weird
thing
you know he's a trickster and he was
very good at that
i mean look he was a democrat
temperamentally for most of his life
you know now so i don't really know what
to make of him
he certainly is a troublemaker by
temperament to
a fair degree and a trickster
that's part of the reason you know i saw
this t-shirt in florida that really had
a big impact on me when i was down there
last year
it said um trump in 2020 because [ __ ]
you twice
and i thought yeah there's something to
that and trump tapped into that
and maybe he tapped into that because
that's genuinely the way he feels
you know he's he's he he also
is not happy with the contempt of the
educated elite which was
definitely something that working-class
americans who supported trump were
reacting to
and i can certainly see that because
i've seen among the
educated literati you know who who
parody what they
think to be my audience i've seen them
deliver virtually nothing but contempt
for
my attempts to help
that you know angry white young male
section of the population
they just have nothing but contempt for
that and
a lot of trump voters were responding to
that and trump tapped into that
extremely well
and i thought you know i thought the dem
hillary lost because she abandoned
her democratic first principles i
thought
she abandoned the working class she
decided she'd go with the identity
politics types instead of the working
class
and i believe that sunk her and rightly
so she deserved that royally
and i think the working class deserves a
voice
and they need a voice they need
dignified work
and a place
that's not just handouts it's not a
solution
people need to be engaged productively
especially if they're conscientious
because their conscience will eat them
if they're not
i wonder if they're taking the topics
like sitting here saying let's see which
one of these we can win and which one of
them we can't win
you know i want to yes they certainly do
some of that and they should
they should that's actually a really
positive part of the political process
in the democracy it's like well those
politicians they're always pandering to
the polls
well you can do that stupidly but like
yeah you're supposed to pander to the
polls those are your people
and you know the wise political
strategists that i'm in touch with
they look for issues that can be
addressed
positively where there is concordance
across both
parties and that's where they they push
say well we seem to both agree on this
that this is useful so let's do that and
that requires goodwill across the
political
table and hopefully there's enough of
that so that
those sorts of things can be managed you
know i'm happy
i would say with biden's infrastructure
goal i think it beats the hell out of
identity politics
and i from what i know of interest
infrastructure development it's
generally generally a wise investment
calculated in terms of return on
investment
you know if it's done without corruption
and
and addressed intelligently
so that's how it looks to me
are you following what janet yellen is
trying to do with uh uh
get corporate taxes to be the same
across the board with g20 where
everybody has
same corporate tax rate to eliminate tax
competition
those are her awards yesterday are you
aware of that or no no i didn't i hadn't
seen that emerge yet
no what what do you think about
you know competition there's competition
in different levels right okay here
jordan peterson be on order where's the
competition on this new york times
ranked fifth
rank sixth ranked first ranked second
ranked tent you're not an atom
it's competition right so we gotta write
a better book so we gotta put a little
more time and research to
write a better book because there's so
much pressure i wrote 12 rules of life
everyone's expecting for
the second one to be better i got to go
compete okay well you know
movies competition health competition
marriage competition
there is a small business i got a small
business if i don't have better customer
service and the right
reviews uh uh online you know uh jordan
if you can
yeah if i don't have the right reviews
online well i may not have people come
to my
restaurant and i'm gonna lose customers
okay great and you know
competition and relationship friendship
well i got to bring value to this
relationship as well or else eventually
this guy's thinking is going to a
different level and i may bore him
eventually because i'm not elevating my
level of thinking
i kind of got to bring value to this
relationship as well in every single
thing
competition plays a good role in us
bringing value
these guys are pitching the idea of
meeting with g20 and telling them that
guys why don't we all come up together
with the same corporate tax rate
because u.s has the current you know one
the highest if not the highest they used
to have the highest at 35
trump brought it down to 21. now they
want a picture to bring you back to 28
to be the biggest
highest i believe in the world europe is
like 9
10 12 they have low corporate tax rate a
lot of them don't even have it
us gotten away with having it why why
is uh why why are they so obsessed with
trying to
create competition for us but eliminate
competition
for themselves what benefit does that do
for everybody well i
i suspect that they're trying to ensure
that
large corporations that are based in
large part in the u.s and that benefit
from let's say the u.s infrastructure
aren't able to escape their corporate
tax burden by
shuffling their resources off to come
countries with a lower tax rate
that would be the goal i mean if it was
just a positive goal i mean
people are complex in their motivations
and you know maybe
who knows how much of straight
anti-capitalism is also motivating that
or irritation at corporations etc etc
um but if you were looking for like a
straightforward
relatively value neutral motivation that
would be it
now i i don't have an opinion about that
at the moment because i don't know
enough about tax policy to formulate an
intelligent opinion
i mean your point you is a temperamental
point at least to some degree you can
see the value in competition and so when
you
see that being eliminated you you see
immediately what the disadvantages of
that might be
and fair enough it's a good rule of
thumb how it applies in this specific
case
that's a really complicated problem and
i i would
the way i would try to address it if i
had to was i'd find three or four people
who
had spent their whole life studying this
sort of thing and i'd go interview them
listen to them you know build up a
certain amount of knowledge if i could
manage it and then maybe
risk an answer i mean it isn't obvious
how to tax corporations
you know because on the one hand you say
well look if you tax them too heavily
they're gonna go somewhere else or
you're going to stop people from
producing corporations
which you definitely don't want to do
obviously there are levels of taxation
that are counterproductively punitive
clearly and then you might have a
discussion about what the benefits
are of taxation in general and people
have a wide range of opinions about that
and validly so
um but the devil's always in the details
that's partly why i wrote chapter six
it's like look these problems are
complicated you have to take them apart
in detail and
and be aware of presuming that your
ideological presumption is going to
accurately reflect what the world is
going to do
very unlikely it's very very unlikely i
don't know what the corporate tax rate
should be
i don't know i i have a corporation
amount i actually actually have
several of them and you know it's in my
personal financial interest
that the corporate tax remain low does
that mean that i'm in favor of a lower
corporate tax rate well it does in that
regard but then i would say i also don't
know enough about
about it in general to make a
generalized conclusion
we've had a lot of economist on and
we've interviewed a lot of guys to see
you know what their thoughts are to kind
of uh see this thing but you know
when it comes down to taxes as complica
as complex as it is um i think
i think even the average person needs to
spend more time
studying taxes it is a form of control
it is a form of uh
it's like working at a company if you're
working in sales what's the first thing
you need to know you need to know your
company's compensation structure
if i sell 20 000 computers to you know
uh walmart's customer service and i'm
working for dell i probably gotta know
how much i want to get paid if i make
sell twenty thousand i think some of the
way the comp structure is being set up
is you know eliminating competition for
themselves that's my bigger concern long
term because
if incentive and innovation goes away
the way it is today what the hell am i
creating anything for like there's got
to be some form of a form of
well that that's that so look i mean
my my answer to that would be if this
seized me as an object of interest
you know and i felt that i wanted to
know more about it that it was an
important topic
i would do what you have done i would go
find people to talk to and
and explore it and all of the avenues
and there's many things that are valid
to be said about that particular issue
and it's worth exploring and then if i
had the opportunity to guide people
through that process that would be good
too
so because then at least in principle we
could all be more informed about it
jordan final thoughts about your book
beyond order final thoughts if you can
tell us a little bit about your book
here how different is this from
12 rules for life well i would say
there are i have a meta
theory i suppose it's not precisely mine
but it's one that i've adopted
um the taoists taoist philosophy
is based on the same set of
presuppositions
it's useful conceptually to divide the
world into things that you can control
and things that you can't
and that's roughly order and chaos so
order is
where you are when the things you're
doing are doing what you want them to do
you're comfortable there that's explored
territory that's the family that's the
state
that's that's tradition that's explored
territory
um where you are when what you're doing
doesn't work well that's upsetting and
unexpected and chaotic and
that's the domain of of nature roughly
speaking
symbolically speaking the first book was
about
how to deal with an excess of chaos
because it can swamp you
and the second book is how to deal with
pathologies of order
and i would also say you know
conservatives are more concerned with
an excess of chaos in managing it
liberals are more concerned with an
excess of order but they're both right
order can go dreadfully wrong i mean
that's what we're talking about when we
talk about the decisions of facebook and
twitter for example to censor
you know we're concerned about that
that's a pathology of order
but the untrammeled world can go
terribly wrong as well which is why we
erect complicated cultural structures to
begin with and so
each book focuses broadly on
one of those two domains and
hypothetically they make a nice matched
set as a consequence
so i tried to the first book tilted more
towards
individuality and anxiety
chaos um and disorder
and but the second book tilts more
towards communitarianism and
um the pathologies of tyranny and how
that might be addressed
they both concentrate fundamentally
though on solutions at the individual
level
you know i'm a psychologist not a
sociologist and i'm primarily interested
in
the level of the individual what can you
do
regardless of the pathologies of the
state or the catastrophes of chaos
what steps can you take to increa
improve your practical understanding of
the world
and to make your way more effectively
even
in your own terms and so
that's the aim of both books and
i'm very pleased that people have
responded
very positively to the newest book as
they did
to the previous one but maybe somewhat
more and
that surprises me because it was written
under a lot of duress and i wasn't sure
at all that
i had managed anything of any quality
um because i i wasn't acute enough often
to
be able to make that distinction but i'm
very pleased that
like the public response on amazon i
think there's
there's several thousand reviews now and
they average out to five stars out of
five and so
and most people have said if they
compare the two books that the second
one is better
so i'm very pleased about that
and and grateful to my
readers happy about its reception
and i do hope that it's helpful that's
what the
goal was that's the goal man it's like
make things better well that's
definitely doing that
you know and you're not holding back in
the book for the person that reads it
you're kind of going here's what i'm
going through here's what
you're not at all holding back it's a
different read than the first one
uh on the cover of it new york times
quote i love how that's on the bottom it
says the most
influential public intellectual
in the western world right now new york
times
specifically from new york times dr
jordan peterson
thank you so much for your time folks if
you're watching this you can
get the book we're going to put the link
below for you to go out there and order
the book
uh i am looking forward to our next
interaction but until then all the best
to you
thank you very much for the discussion
and thank you to all of you who are
watching and listening uh it's much
appreciated and
good luck to all of you no matter when i
speak to him this man makes you think
you know the way he processes issues and
how he's
thinking and processing out loud so he's
kind of well i would do it
and just kind of follow him to see where
his mind goes and where his brain takes
him but
if you enjoy today's interviews there's
two other interviews i did with them
that are just as fascinating as this one
one of them i did in dallas was the
first one we ever did when he talked
about how he makes decision
if you've never seen this very
interesting the other one is
the clip that i showed where he was
emotional
we did that interview in front of seven
or eight thousand people if you've never
seen that one
click over here to watch that interview
take care everybody bye